so nur zu einer frage die mir selber
schon aus sämtlichen körperöffnungen
raushängt warum zum henker ist andreas
scheuer immer noch im amt warum heuer
oder wie ich ihn inzwischen liebevoll
nennung unser flunkern mariechen im auto
untersuchungsausschuss gab es gerade
einen regelrechten showdown gegen die
mautbetreiber zwei firmenchefs sagen
natürlich haben wir schon angeboten mit
der unterzeichnung der mietverträge auf
das urteil zu warten wollte der an die
aber nicht wegen wahlkampf so wer lügt
denn jetzt ich werde ihm niemals
übergeben und sagen er lügt ich kann nur
über mich sagen und wir würden wir in
schulenberg wie es sagen die wahrheit
ich werde niemals sagen schon übt er
sagt nur das gegenteil von der wahrheit
sehr schön sehr schön fürs protokoll es
war heuer der mehrere gespräche mit dem
mautbetreiber erstmal komplett
verschwiegen hat warum wohl
und es war scheuer der letztes jahr den
bundestag jetzt ja nicht im juristischen
sinne belogen hat aber gab es das
angebot der betreiber jetzt hat sie eine
- war nicht thema in dem gespräch haben
22 november a
merken sie was es gab kein angebot am 22
november
da bleiben wir noch 364 andere tage das
nennt sich übrigens ein über
spezifisches dementi
so nennt der fachmann das von einem über
spezifischen dementi spricht man wenn
mit der absicht eine richtigstellung
oder einen widerspruch vorzutäuschen das
dementi bewusst konkreter formuliert
wurde als nötig ist clever mein schatz
am letzten dienstag hatte ich keinen sex
mit unserer nachbarin gut gemacht
inzwischen sagt schau ja nur noch er
kann sich an so ein angebot der
mautbetreiber zitat nicht mehr erinnern
aha dürfte noch mal ganz kurz auf meine
eingangsfrage zurückkommen warum ist er
noch im amt warum kommt da nicht mehr
druck vom koalitionspartner spd
man vermutet da gibt es einen
nichtangriffspakt die sozen halten die
füße still in sachen steuer
dafür bot die union nicht groß nach bei
olaf scholz
erschreckend viele politiker leiden
gerade unter gedächtnisverlust
[Musik]
das robert koch institut warnt vermeiden
sie reisen ins berliner
regierungsviertel
in diesem gebäude grassiert ein neues
virus die symptome dramatische
gedächtnislücken und durchfall artiger
verlust von steuergeld hier patient null
ein anonymisierter verkehrsminister er
kann sich absolut nicht erinnern wo er
über eine halbe milliarde euro für die
maut vergraben hat ebenfalls infiziert
dieser kanzlerkandidat auf die frage ob
er sich noch an gespräche mit
skrupellosen comex bank an erinnert sagt
er genau im endstadium weiß der patient
nicht mal mehr bei welcher partei er mal
vorsitzender war die grünen traurig kurz
gesagt berlin berlinfahrt bloß nicht
nach berlin
sage ich seit jahren hartnäckige
gedächtnislücken also bei den herren
scheuer und stolz über fünf stunden
wurde der verkehrsminister im
untersuchungsausschuss gegrillt am ende
für nichts und wieder nichts aussage
gegen aussage
kollege lanz hat alle entscheidenden
antworten von ihm in viereinhalb
sekunden rausgekitzelt ok also keinen
fehler und sich auch nichts vorzuwerfen
nein natürlich nicht
neulich hat er ja schon wieder eine
pkw-maut vorgeschlagen dieses mal für
ganz europa immerhin der u ausschuss
will es demnächst mit ich zitiere neuen
untersuchungsmethoden versuchen
ich dachte erst ich meinen sowas aber es
soll wohl nur ne art kreuzverhör geben
auch schön mir persönlich würde für den
anfang ja schon ein hauch von
selbstkritik genügen skandal works
vertuschung rücktritt nebelkerzen etc
ok gar nicht schlecht was ist mit
debakel debakel habe ich noch vergessen
genau
gern geschehen an die man ganz naiv
gefragt kann die frau merkel den ich
einfach entlassen ja um der
politikverdrossenheit vorzubeugen klar
was die mode angeht müsste sie
eigentlich die ganze csu fordern aber
das geht ja nicht
hoffentlich schreibt sie ihm wenigstens
ein mieses arbeitszeugnis
ich finde das an die steuer eine sehr
gute arbeit macht da muss sie selber
lachen ja meine gibt bestimmt irgendwo
in deutschland irgendein an die scheuer
der gute arbeit macht im
verkehrsministerium garantiert nicht
ewig kann er sich doch so nicht halten
ich behaupte sogar heimlich sucht die
csu längst den nachfolger wird dich
jetzt und werde der neue an die scheuer
du bist jung titel hast führerschein
klasse 3 und seinen doktortitel an
irgendeiner witz ohne gekauft dann wäre
doch verkehrsminister die elite die
besten der besten haben diesen job noch
nie gemacht aber du könntest die machen
genau wie an die hast du 300 top
bezahlte anwälte unter dir die rund um
die uhr die scheiße aus bünde du baust
erwarten von jedem bewerber die absolute
bereitschaft nichts dazu zu lernen und
die selben fehler immer und immer wieder
zu machen wie der an die wenn dir zum
beispiel der bundesrechnungshof sagt
autobahnbau mit privaten firmen es viel
teurer bestellst du trotzdem für vier
milliarden neue autobahnen bei privaten
firmen dann verspricht der totale
transparenz aber wenn einer die zahlen
sehen will
der haushaltspolitiker sven christian
kindler bekam die unterlagen zur a3 und
zu a 49 nach monaten zwar ausgehändigt
aber erst nachdem sämtliche zahlen aus
den berechnungen gelöscht waren
das alles weiß alles rausgeholt hinten
grünen können doch ähnlich rechnen von
dir als bewerber erwarten wir eine fast
schon kindliche begeisterung für das
deutsche automobil
das ist der spirit und amman die haben
wir letztes jahr 61 neue
autobahnkilometer gebaut
122 kilometer bundesstraße aber nur
sechs kilometer neue trassen für die
bahn
greta verkehrsminister kein job für
jeden der muss schon sehr vieler mars
vorbei gehen deswegen schicken wir
unsere talentscouts sogar in kitas und
suchen nach den andys von morgen
da sehe ich doch schon ein kommt zu uns
und lernen in praktischen übungen die
man sich an sein amt klammert egal was
du verbockt hast nie freiwillig dass
büroräume absolut würdelos das könntest
du sein wird dich jetzt
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
mimen ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen
scheiß und liegt - wollt dann abonniert
jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist ein minimal hersteller
[Musik]